this is a fresh take on that issue
putting you at the center of the
national conversation
i'm trevor phillips and this is the
great debate
[Applause]
first a warning that this episode may
contain stories and language which some
viewers might find offensive
tonight as we discuss one of the most
personal and divisive issues facing
society our viewers panel from across
the country indeed across the world will
have they say they'll share their
stories
joining us in the studio this week are
former yorkshire cricket captain azim
rafiq who's given evidence to mps about
racism he endured in the sport
dr martin newsom cognitive
anthropologist at the universities of
oxford and kent
tom thurlwell
chief executive of copper 90 a fan first
football media company
and former lioness leanne sanderson who
won 50 cats for england
the big question facing us all tonight
is racism in sport here to stay
it only took a matter of minutes after
england's heartbreaking defeat to remind
us of the ugly side of football
for some of them to be abused is
unforgivable really in manchester a
mural of marcus rashford was defaced
with racist slurs
players continuing to take the knee in
pursuit of equality for the first time i
started to see for what it was felt
isolated
humiliated at times scene rafik has
shown a light on our game that has
shocked
shamed and saddened us all racism and
discrimination
is a blight on our game eight clubs have
signed a letter accusing england hockey
of having an issue with endemic racism
sadly it's become somewhat of a
norm for people that have my skin color
what is the government doing it's almost
getting back to that level this is still
going on and you know you just think
when will it end
let's start as ever with our viewers
panel and talk to
aaron simpson aaron
i experienced racism probably for the
first time when i was maybe seven or
eight and i've played football for
ever since then really and the first
encounter i can kind of remember was
playing with my friends
um just kind of sunday league and a
parent actually made a racial slur
towards me whilst i was playing
and at the time i didn't really
understand i don't think the
the kind of the significant of the
significance of what he said but um
kind of what sticks in my mind is my
doubts my dad's reaction as he was on
the sideline and um he's such a chilled
and laid back person so to see his
reaction and
all of a sudden come become really
defensive over me um makes that really
stick out in my mind as something uh
that
that was obviously something a lot
bigger than than than what i thought it
was what was his reaction aaron
um he he just lost his lost his temper
and obviously con confronted the guy
about about kind of what he said and and
he denied it obviously um but but it
wasn't just kind of my dad that that
heard it so um yeah and
the funny thing is that that agent just
kind of continued to play and didn't
really think anything of it but as i've
got older i've
sadly experienced um more racism as i
went into the professional game and
more recently i had an incident in
non-league football where um we had a
black striker and as he scored a goal um
the
opposition fans behind the goal started
doing the monkey chants and it was just
the most surreal experience it was like
someone almost had clicked their fingers
and
we kind of teleported to somewhere like
russia or somewhere where you would
maybe expect a little bit more more
racism and at the time
the team i was playing in was
probably i think we had maybe eight or
nine black or mixed race players um so
yeah the manager after the the incident
happened um the manager took us both uh
both teams inside and and basically said
if you if you kind of want to want to
stop the game and and stuff i fully
support you
what did you do erin what happened
so we actually continued to play the
game
and we actually ended up winning as well
so i think that that was a that was a
big thing for us because it it kind of
solidified us as a team and and the fact
that there was like i say a large
majority of black and ethnic players uh
playing um has meant that
since we've all moved on we've kind of
stayed in touch because we shared that
crazy experience together one more goal
than them is probably a good answer to
that but hold on there for a second
aaron azim
your story has now become
rather well known does that resonate
with you
yeah very much so i mean i uh for a very
long time i didn't see it for what it
was either um it wasn't until right at
the end of my second spell that things
started to dawn out on me what was
actually happening um in 2017 i reported
it as bullying because i think for a
person of color to actually start
accepting as well that you're being
treated differently because of your skin
or your religion it's quite difficult to
take
and can be quite damaging mentally so
yeah it completely resonates and it took
me a very long time to understand what
it was
when you reported it as bullying was
that because you didn't want to think
that it was because of your race or
because you just didn't see it that way
a bit of both i think i was in denial
for a very long time i'd been struggling
since 2013
with my mental health taking medication
and not quite knowing what was affecting
me
so i think when you around 2017
um it was starting to sort of touch me a
little bit what is going on but again i
didn't want to i wanted to look the
other way i wanted to pretend that it
wasn't because of my race but
as we went through 2017 and into 2018 it
became quite evident that i was being
treated differently because of my race
yeah you um
said that uh in the way that
the
club yorkshire county cricket club
treated you and some of the other
players treated you it was clear that
you were disadvantaged because of your
race but of course one of the issues
that's come up since then is that this
doesn't always just go one way you
yourself um
have been it's alleged that you
made anti-semitic statements
yeah i mean uh so after dcms when the
them messages surfaced um i felt sick to
my stomach
i don't really know why i held them
views but clearly i'd said them things
and i was very clear as soon as the
surface that i was not going to try and
put any excuse to it i apologized uh
straight away to the jewish community
and i allowed them to decide so what the
consequences i had to go through
there was a gap in my learning which i'm
trying to bridge that now and trying to
spend as much time as possible with them
to try and understand why them views
and make sure that the issue as well i
think what did help was in that it
showed how big the issue actually was
and it kept the issue right at the
forefront of people's minds when they
tried to brush it away okay of course
this tells us that there are many
dimensions to this issue
but i want to come to joshua thompson
smith because i think joshua you have if
you like
a broad question for our panel that
encompasses many of these issues joshua
yeah so i'm a massive sports fan um for
all sports live
football especially i've been going
since i was a junior member at the club
that i support and recently just went
only uh the last weekend
i wouldn't say i feel massively
empowered at a sports stadium to stand
up to 15
20
uh men that are all drunk and
potentially
uh exercising racial slurs
and i think that's where the question is
what more can be done at sports events
um to essentially help fans to stand up
to racism in sport thank you joshua
so panel here's our first question
from joshua what can be done to help
fans stand up to racism in sport tom
uh well i think it's a it's a it's a
great question and one that was
i thought really brought home at the
euros last year because
the scenes that you saw around the final
and fans breaking through the barriers
and
uh you know over drug taking
i think football stadiums have become
very permissive environments um
in a study a couple of years ago 2019 i
think it was that 70 percent of people
had
kind of witnessed the abusive race of
racist language uh within um football
grounds so i think there needs to be
stronger sanctions i think there needs
to be better training and equipping of
stewards to recognize and then uh eject
and and kind of ban fans from the
environment i think there needs to be
uh far greater education which is a
sometimes an overused word in in this
space but i just i just think that there
is
the the learned behaviors that see
uh drunk
uh
football fans entering an environment
feeling like
broadly they can behave however they
like
has to be brought to an end yeah and um
football indeed now cricket some other
sports have been saying for many years
sanctions we're going to train
people we're going to shut people out of
the game um your experience
is that what has actually happened
yeah i think so i mean to pick up on
something that tom said as well i think
at these games you know it's difficult
to report it because then when you do
report it you maybe have somebody that
will know you've reported it and start
being aggressive towards you so it's
difficult but i think from my experience
i've certainly noticed that allies are a
big big factor in everything we're doing
because i can sit here and talk about
you know i think i take all the right
boxes in my eyes but i'm a woman you
know i'm gay and i'm black so for some
people that's a lot for them to handle
and so i do experience it every day
every day i walk in this life right in
this world i do but at football stadiums
i think it's difficult because it's like
if people report it they don't know what
the repercussions will be because you
know there's 50 000 60 000 people at
football stadium and it's difficult and
for people to you know sometimes say
racism doesn't exist in this country
it's beyond me because after the final
when rashford and sakha was racially
abused i wasn't surprised a lot of
people were surprised and i think that
is the dangerous thing that people were
surprised that happened because it still
happens it hasn't gone away racism
hasn't gone away it's been here forever
and the fact that we'll have these
conversations tonight i think makes a
difference as well okay i want to pick
up this point about how difficult it is
when you actually confront it and i want
to talk to
our panel uh viewers panel again and
talk to uh tilly
i think you've got an experience that
you want to share with us tilly
yeah so um i'd finished playing a rugby
game and we headed to the pub that's
sort of the equivalent of our clubhouse
and there was an older white gentleman
sitting near us we were watching the six
nations game at the time and as he got
up to go he made a comment that the
england rugby team was a lot better ten
years ago than it was today
and then followed up that by saying
because there's too many obviously um
this is uncensored n words on the team
now
um and you know he said this brazenly in
a pub with you know people of color
rugby teammates nearby and obviously me
and my teammates started shouting at him
that it's completely unacceptable and
basically asked the bar staff to remove
him straight away and they did and they
were really apologetic about it but it
was quite shocking really
martin newsom this issue here about how
you actually deal with it i mean we can
have
laws we can
uh
politicians and everybody else can make
statements but actually sometimes it
comes down to this situation you are
standing next to somebody
who behaves in this way what do you do
it's great to hear that tilly felt safe
enough to take action immediately and
that is probably one of the most
effective things we can do
calling it out nipping it in the bud
speaking up
but it's not always easy to do it's
called being a bystander do you stand
back and let something happen or do you
step in the world never got changed by
people standing back do you need to take
action
but we need leadership to show us that
it is
appropriate and needed and respected
and our leaders in our society not just
within football but our whole society is
structured around a racist structure
with not enough leadership for people of
color okay we can come back to this
issue of leadership during our programme
but
emmanuel ojingma uh i think emmanuel are
in um in east london
what have you got tell us
yeah trevor i think um
part of the challenge we have actually
is
the atmosphere and most sporting event
is electrifying
it gives people the idea that they are
invisible and
it's kind of difficult you know they
think it's just banter you know when
they engage in such acts so um it's
really challenging you know to try to um
isolate what is actually banter from um
racism itself i think this this came up
when you were giving evidence at um the
parliamentary select committee how do
you tell the difference between
banter between mates who just pick out
some characteristic some of us are tall
some of us are short some of us are dark
some of us are white etc and actual
racist abuse how do you know when you
when you see it
i think um
a couple of things i've been mentioned
bad things happen when good people do
nothing so the bystanders and i mean
it's really great that tilly felt like
she could do what she did um and if that
would have happened a lot more in my
situation it would have stopped
leadership again is so important trying
to make sure that it's very clear where
the boundaries are especially within
sporting dressing rooms
so for me
it's really important that we don't just
be that bystanders and just allow things
to happen because they're faster and
they become bigger and they become
institutionalized
sometimes when you speak out and be that
person you become ostracized because i
feel like when i've spoken out about
certain things with my old england
manager and stuff like that you feel
like people then start attacking you but
when you are being you know racially
abused or when you see someone else it's
a feeling you get in your stomach you
know when you can say what's the
difference between banter it's never
banter in my opinion when it comes to
that type of thing but i felt like for
myself when i stood up for myself in
previous i'm sure as he feels the same
you feel like you receive pelters for
being honest and that's the difficult
thing but thankfully if people like
kazeem and other people that are
standing up and make people like tilly
that allow because i can't believe that
guy in the pub has got to the age that
he has and no one's educated him and
that's the scary thing in itself because
now that man will realize he cannot say
that how has he got to that i think she
said she said he was an older guy
nobody's corrected him ever in life and
that's the scary thing we are going to
come back to this issue of education uh
in a later part but for the moment
this is the great debate up next
are social media companies doing enough
to stop players being racially abused on
their platforms
companies can no longer ignore some of
the appalling vile racist violence and
april content that appear on their
platforms
players shouldn't have to go through
this they should do something more than
that they allowed those people to split
the races now a majority of the abusive
tweets we take down we detected using
technology
[Music]
oh my goodness so this historic night
where you've got these female winners
history making coder winning best
picture and none of that is being
discussed this morning this is all about
will smith and chris rock like uk at
first i thought this is one of those
dreadful contrived sort of mock rivalry
banter thing going on that they try and
do and fail at the oscars but no it was
a lot more serious and i think the
gravity of the situation presented
itself very quickly to the audience you
i mean lupita little guy who's who sat
behind will smith is basically our
barometer for this her face went from
being a smiling grin and going along
with the apparent gag to this dawning
realization and i think we all we all
have a little bit of inner lupita in us
this morning thinking what just went
down so yes oh my goodness will smith
what a narrative arc that man's been on
this was meant to be his redemption
night this was the oscar not just for
king richard but for 30 years tireless
work
being this beacon of success in
hollywood a big old blockbuster movie
star turned character actor and being
rewarded accordingly and instead oh what
can you say what can you think okay
right now will smith must just be
looking at his oscar in one corner of
his room and all the social media and
commentary and reaction across the world
in the other
funny old story i think he'll be talking
about this for a long time
it was everything that a journalist
might want in a story a story that you'd
be proud to have filmed
that they didn't want journalists to see
the real story
it was very tiring it was very sad it
was very scary at times
but you have to keep going
look at that
you don't want to lecture people
[Music]
[Music]
b
[Music]
so
[Applause]
i love my job because
i get to do something that is
contributing to a better future
[Music]
welcome back to the great debate where
this week we're asking
is racism in sport here to stay
almost all non-white athletes are now
the target of racist abuse on social
media
a missed penalty poor performance or the
wrong side winning can result in sports
stars receiving a barrage of hateful
comments from faceless accounts
companies are under pressure to do more
to stop online abuse being sent or seen
but are they acting quickly enough
connor
connor sumrall good evening uh old
friend of the show in mansfield connor
what's your view about this
well i think social media has become
such a big part of life players have
become more exposed to the racism
and it's common enough things like death
threats to be on there and the situation
only seems to be getting worse
so my question to the panel is what will
it take for companies to put people
before profits and stop racism on their
platforms
thank you connor connor's question for
the panel is what will it take for
companies to put people before profits
and stop racism on their platforms
leanne
yeah i mean i'm a big advocate for and a
lot of people have said you know it's an
invasion of privacy for passports and
some kind of form of identification to
be shown when people are signing up
because you know i receive you know i
have a love-hate relationship with
social media i think it's a fantastic
way of being able to engage with people
but the amount of abuse i get on a daily
basis you know when i've gone on say a
male probably followed account whether
it be talk sports sky sports news i
don't really check my phone anymore
during shows because it's so
disappointing to see what people write
so for me you know if i put music up on
my social media it gets taken down
straight away you know because they're
saying oh you know it's copyright
infringement and stuff like that i just
had a video a couple of days ago taken
down for about five years ago so if they
can find that how can they not stop
people from being able to get to you
because you look at footballers
everybody's all creatures of habit they
look at their phone straight away after
a game and i can handle someone telling
me you know i don't like you because
you're not a very good pundit that's
their opinion but when it comes to race
you know sexuality or the color of your
skin or the fact that i'm a woman those
are things i can't change and that's
what i have a hard time with and i've
had so much abuse from people martha do
you think um we can do anything about
this without
interfering on in an unwarranted way
with people's freedom of expression
i think the problem with social media
platforms is that
there's a degree of anonymity you can
hide behind it so the question is is
really
is this something you're willing to say
to someone's face is it something you'd
be willing someone to say to you
how accountable are you able to be for
that so the the idea that of having some
form of verification could potentially
work and if people don't want to sign up
for that then perhaps they have to have
to ask themselves why not
um
this anonymity also breeds a lack of
empathy
so it's
you're one step removed you're behind
the wall but that other person as well
you're not you're not seeing their
reactions you're not seeing the hurt
that it has let me come back to
another member of our viewers panel
uh vasilyki contour
watson good evening versalicky
hello hello what's your view
i think
i mean i think that quite a few people
were shocked with the amount of
vitriolic abuse racial abuse towards the
the england players after the world cup
i think that social media has provided a
a platform whereby anybody can log on
and say whatever they like and nothing
can be done about it i mean i work with
schools myself and i've had to intervene
in a lot of racist bullying as the
outcome of online commentary i think
that if we're not careful racism will
only get worse as young
people's identities are entrenched in
social
media i think as that is the case in
addition to
educating people about online etiquette
we need to be
to have more safeguarding measures in
place for
uh people with access to to social media
okay
let me come back to you as in you've
probably uh experienced as much of this
as most people
nobody likes online abuse but
maybe we should there's one thing to
bear in mind sometimes people want to be
able to say something about what's
happened to them
they themselves have been victims of
domestic abuse or racist views and so on
and they don't want to put their names
out there what do we what should we do
about that
yeah i mean it's it's a really tricky
one but
not having a verification i don't i
don't understand why like leanne said
that if they can't have verification why
is it that they're not having it i have
a love-hate relationship with social
media uh because actually if it wasn't
for social media i'm not sure if i would
have been heard so it was a massive
platform for me i used it um
regularly to try and speak about my own
experiences uh when
it was really difficult to be heard in
mainstream media so um
but on the flip side of it around dcm
especially the amount of abuse i got it
it was hurtful
to read some of the comments um and it
was difficult not to read them when
people tell you oh just ignore it it's
not that easy and then words they stay
with you let me come back to
our wall
because i think uh
we have um
some people who've got some ideas here
about what you could do ishmael fontaine
ishmael
hello sir hi
um i agree with the verification um idea
i'd also like to tell you guys that i
don't believe that it's a priority for
for um social media companies to combat
racism they haven't there's no priority
at all
covid was this brand new thing we did
not know where it came from there was
all these conspiracy theories it came
from a lab it came from this person
eating a bat it came from all these
things and as soon as we and as soon as
we understood what misinformation was
and what was damaging to society the
social media platforms cut it out very
very quickly not only that the governing
bodies of all sports had a whole
protocol when it came to governing covid
they don't have a protocol governing
racism all right there's new ideas every
day that need to come about okay ishmael
thank you uh leanne could they do more
in the way that they have done with
clovid definitely i mean when i report
it i get a generic response so i think
that just about sums it up and some of
the abuse i've received myself i mean
it's not all about me but i can only go
off of what i receive and if i report it
they'll get a generic response back so
it's all very well saying these media
these social media companies are doing
everything they can to combat it but are
they because if i'm reporting it and i'm
getting a generic response then you know
it you couldn't get more offensive it
says oh this doesn't breach the rules of
twitter or whatever it might be but how
much more offensive could they be with
what they're saying because i won't even
repeat what they've said to me okay
going back on to something leanne said
earlier
when you have a copyright strike
that affects them financially you get
taken down very very quickly
quickly so on top of the social media
companies policing it we want other
individuals in the fan community
policing and we want the football
governing bodies getting in there
straight away direct action not these
long and lengthy procedures to have a
formal uh policy in place but quick
interventions from individuals all right
we are going to talk actually about the
sports authorities and the
nature of those authorities in a moment
coming up after the break we'll be
joined by former england footballer john
barnes
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this is the great debate is racism in
sport here to stay
and before we come back to our viewers
panel we're joined by the former england
footballer well actually football star i
should say john barnes good evening john
um good evening i was looking at your
book and the inside cover of the book
there is the now iconic photograph of
you
back healing
a banana
back in the liverpool days that's now
three decades ago
do you think things have changed
in terms of overt racism um things have
probably got better than it was back
then but in the last two years we've
seen it very rare it's ugly head
obviously on social media and of course
some football fans have been more
emboldened to actually show their true
colors at football man however what i
always say is that as long as
football racism exists in society to
exist in all sorts of society which
football is one so why do we believe we
can get rid of it in football
but we
but we're not getting within society
we're doing it the other way around
until we tackle it in society in schools
education you know access to social care
all those things it'll exist in all
walks of society of which football is
only one so as i said racism has never
gone away it's always been there but now
people are i don't know why they're now
being more emboldened to actually raise
their rather very ugly head to actually
come out and abuse people
martha newsom here in the studio made a
a point a moment ago about the
question of leadership what our
political leaders say what uh the
people in education say and so on um
thinking about the footballing and
sporting authorities specifically do you
think they're offering the kind of
leadership that you would expect
well i think if you look at the
leadership we're offering what we're
doing is we are looking at people be it
on social media be it with romanian
force officials be it with football fans
in eastern europe we're tackling people
who are inconsequential to systemic bias
we're not tackling the root cause of
systemic bias in this country which
causes knife crime and apathy towards
black people generally speaking and
apathy towards helping um education uh
and that's that's the system but what
we're doing is pointing the finger at
some 12 year old racist football fan and
people on twitter idiots on twitter and
believe that as long as we get rid of
them everything will be okay we have to
look at society and take responsibility
at a much higher level in terms of
systemic bias that is in the system that
we all are a part of and tackle it there
rather than you know just just having
making gestures where would you start
then
management administration and so on i
start with us admitting as human beings
every one of us that we do discriminate
we do we see we see we see the world in
terms of racial hierarchy and a big
example of that is what i'm completely
behind ukraine we have complete empathy
for people in ukraine but of course we
have more empathy for them than we do
have people in mali and chad where
they've had wars for 20 years so we do
believe in social in in racial hierarchy
but unfortunately we believe that unless
i throw an arm on the field i'm not
racist unless i sexually abuse a woman
i'm not sexist we all are but we have to
understand how we are why we have become
so because of how we've been conditioned
for hundreds of years to see the world
in that way and deconstruct what we have
learned
but until we start the process and just
point the finger the idiots who get
caught like people on twitter and people
who throw it on the field and we say
they're the problem martin luther king
said in 1963 that is the shallow
understanding of racial bias by good
people meaning me you all of us
we are the problem not the total
misunderstanding by bad people the total
misunderstanding by bad people are
idiots on twitter people who throw
bananas on the field and we think if we
get rid of them everything will be okay
john thank you so much uh i wish we
could talk more but another time
thank you
let's go back to uh
our viewers panel and pick up some of
those points i can see
people applauding what john bonds had to
say talk to shimbakatima in manchester
a famous sporting city shimba what's
your thought
uh it's a trevor absolute pleasure to
meet you to talk to you and everybody
else um
i had the enormous uh pleasure to be
to play amateur rugby and uh some
professional rugby when i graduated from
university
um
best summer the best years of my life
undoubtedly but as a black player
as a black man you did notice there was
differences uh in
and
i say a few
members a few members of the team so you
wouldn't get recognition from by doing
certain things
on the pitch um
extra roughness from extra roughness
from the opposition no protection from
the referees
and because of that protection you will
keep on saying because because of that
lack of protection
you are always mindful what you say to
the referee so you'd actually almost be
apologetic when you're going to the
referee to uh to state your case
that's that's very interesting and that
annoyance you wouldn't see from out
off the pitch but
you've got a question for our uh studio
arising out of that
i do i do um i think the question is
what can we
how can we truly
how can sport truly be inclusive at all
levels
so much
question from shimba
how can we make sport truly inclusive at
all levels tom
we'll pick you up on something that uh
john barnes said as well that that um
racism is systemic therefore we need to
look at the system and if we look at the
system of football we need to look
top to bottom
about
kind of
where
racism
exists and where
it's just not being addressed and you
know the the end points of this that
we've been talking about are part of it
of course but
you know the
vfa i went to a a an england match um
as a guest of the fa
three four years ago now and
of 120 people in the room there was
five people that were from an ethnic
minority and three women and that was
that was it and so
if that's what it looks like at the top
then that flows
that flows down and that is the system
that is the system that's been
constructed and we need to reset that
system all right i'm going to come back
and i'm going to talk to our guests in
the studio particularly leanne before we
do that i want to bring in
it's a positive night of stars and i
want to bring in shauna brown
the quinn's harlequins uh
forward
what do you think about this point
that's being made shauna about the
importance of inclusion of all kinds
me the inclusion is is what i live for
and it's it's what i've become so
morally attached to and growing up i
grew up in south london and and
difference was not only encouraged but
celebrated and it was about people
bringing their different selves to
school like for instance i went to
primary school and our house names were
after like rosa parks was a house name
martin luther king was a house named
mary seacole was a house name
and that was normal that wasn't for
black history month like that that was
just our everyday we would have all
different languages of how to say hello
as you walked into the school but then
as i've grown up and moved out of london
and currently live in kent
it's the
realizing almost how lucky i was and
lucky's not not the term that i should
be using because actually this should be
for everyone but it's the like get every
everybody getting used to difference and
so often people want to want to say
we're the same and want to be treated
the same and actually i would challenge
the the whole idea of equality because
it's not about equality it's not about
treating people the same it's about
treating people how they need to be
treated and whether that's talking to
them differently and you know you have a
conversation with one person in a
certain tone and and that person gets a
message but you can have exactly the
same conversation with exactly the same
tone exactly the same words and someone
else can take it completely differently
like four different reasons because of
potentially their upbringing because of
the color of their skin because of the
sport they play so it's about treating
people how they need to be treated and
the only way we can find out how they
need to be treated is to talk to them to
find out about them okay
liam sanderson this is a very
interesting point isn't it particularly
in team sports
you've got a range of personalities
range of background ranges of
experiences
but if you treat everybody as though
they're the same
maybe that's as bad as
some of the other things we've been
talking about yeah to a certain degree
but you know i think i was very
fortunate when i played for arsenal that
i was always treated with the utmost
respect but i felt like for me i've
lived in spain i lived in italy you know
i've lived in cyprus and it is difficult
you know she touched upon the fact that
you go somewhere where you belong is so
powerful because for me i've left
countries based upon not feeling like i
belong somewhere and that's sort of it's
a feeling that you get you know it's not
necessarily that someone doesn't look
like me but you get really strange
stares and people look at you and stuff
like that so i do think it's a really
you know interesting thing to talk about
place of belonging because i think
that's so powerful okay let's come back
to shimba katima shimba you've been
listening um
what do you think
talk to us about your experience i think
you've got um
you've got a a son i think who's
involved in sports i do
i do so like thankfully i mean i think
i'm touching on all that and talking
about what shawn it's going through it's
um my son is eight years old he's the
only bla is the only black kid
i mean there's a mixed-race child but
he's the only black kid in his team but
his coach andy um
you know
he treats he's just for cook for my son
he's just another player he's just
another kid
thankfully he hasn't experienced
anything i haven't experienced anything
aaron's
has experienced so do i think there's
hope i like to think so you know i'm
optimistic that way i mean i can't speak
highly enough for andy uh and what he's
actually doing so and and sometimes you
know let's let's call it out but at the
same time you know let's let's give
praise where you know let's get praise
where there is and i can't praise andy
enough
chamber thank you well
that's an interest sean that's an
interesting note of optimism do you
share that
yeah for sure like you want to when you
walk into a team sport especially that
you want to be treated
as one of the players and the same way
so when i talk about the difference and
celebrating difference and treating
people they need to be treated an
example of a rugby player who wears a
hijab zainab
she during eid got a video message from
from all of her her team and rugby
playing team to just say happy eid and
like you're not going to do that for
someone who's not muslim so for me
that's the positivity in celebrating our
difference and yes there's an element of
sort of being treated the same but
actually being treated the same means
that sense of belonging that sense of
welcoming and that's not always skin
color like that's as lian just
spoke about it's actually culturally as
well so that's that there would be there
would be white people who i can relate
to modern black but it for me it'd be
like the london sort of the urban
environment the city environment there
would be black people who i don't relate
to because you know they might have gone
to a private school or they might have
grown up on a farm in the country like
it's not necessarily always skin color
it's that cultural sense of belonging
but you've got that so belonging and
inclusion
seanan brown thank you so much for
joining us this evening
thank you trevor
watching the great debate after the
break we'll be asking
is racism in sport a reflection of
society as a whole
the wind was like pulling us out of that
little room
[Music]
mandatory evacuation you must leave
i'm greg milam sky's u.s correspondent
here in los angeles
it is almost impossible to predict where
these fires will go next
[Music]
we aim to be the best and most trusted
place for news
[Music]
this gives you an idea of the strength
of those wins strong enough to bend and
twist metal
are you trying to run me over sir
phillip no go away look like it sir
will you respond to those who made
accusations so philip can you go away
i've seen the dark side of america
we are standing on the supply line right
into the heart of america's opioid
crisis
[Music]
i've seen heartbreaking human stories
there was a river of blood coming out of
the mosque that's a scene that you don't
forget
christchurch has been changed forever by
what happened
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i love my job because
i get to do something that is
contributing to a better future
[Music]
[Music]
is racism in sport here to stay
that's a topic of the great debate this
week of course racism isn't confined to
sport it's part of
our society in pretty much every area
we're going to start by hearing from ken
isaacs in nottingham
ken i think you've got a question for us
on this point
yeah firstly can i say that there's been
some horrific experiences recounted but
some truly uplifting responses to them
the direct answer to the question at the
start of the show is yes it is here to
stay and the reason i say that um is
that measures sports used to tackle it
over the years
uh
worked in a limited fashion however
there's still sporadic incidents finding
by governing bodies is pathetic
punishing all fans for the action of one
or two is unfair and education has only
had limited effects and of course it's
wrong but my question to the panel is
how do you solve the unsolvable when
racism is part of society
thank you ken
big question there
for our panel how do you solve the
unsolvable when racism is part of
society
martha newton you've got 30 seconds to
sort that one out
well you change society society's not
fixed it changes all the time ideas
change racism is just an idea
we're not built
to
necessarily put people apart in racial
groups the actual construct of race
itself is only an idea
racial groups don't have a genetic basis
in the way that we often think they do
so this whole idea of racism race is
changeable and it's fluid it does not
have to stick so we change society we
change our values both as individuals
calling people out and at a top level as
well direct and quick response from
authoritative bodies
azim society first
sport
will follow
completely disagree um it's one of the
things that irritates me the most you
hear it all the time oh yeah but it's a
societal problem i think it's such a
cop-out um if i if my part in society is
that i'm involved in cricket and i try
and sort out where i am
then hopefully that will build into the
society and help sell society out and if
everyone does that within their spaces
then hopefully the the problem that
unsolvable which i don't think is
unsolvable uh it just we've never found
a solution but we've got a chance i feel
like in the last couple of years there's
a bit more of an energy and a bit more
more people calling it out more of the
big voices getting involved and i think
it's for all of us to now make sure that
we stand by each other and change things
martha i agree that we have to tackle it
directly in sport as well as a society
level in football there is a danger of
it being a potential breeding ground and
we don't want to lump fans together
there's a big danger in that there are
fans who are socially and politically
motivated in a way that they've never
been before the last five years has seen
a big growth in that so we want to use
those movements to the best that we can
the reason football is a potential
breeding ground for racism and it can
explode quite quickly is because of the
ritual environment that you're in with
football you've got these heightened
emotions you've got chanting which are
not just racist but sexually motivated
against lgbtq plus community and so on
so it can really explode very quickly
through the sort of rituals in fan
culture and because of this us versus
them psychology we are all built to to
know who's in or out of our group but it
doesn't have to be based on race all
right let me come to
an actual fan mena
saleh
who uh i think is from west london don't
have to say which team but uh manor what
what's your thought about this issue
society or sport first
um it's definitely sports first i think
it starts from the top of sports and
works its way down obviously i play
uh i play football and played football
and semi-professional setups and amateur
men set ups uh for for throughout my
life and like you said i'm from west
london it's a pretty multicultural area
so i played in multicultural teams but
we do have to go away to teams that are
a bit outside of london and play against
teams that are completely white from the
top to the bottom that be the managers
all the players the staff
etc
and uh most recently we played against
one of them teams and i got called a
turk and got told to go back to my kebab
shop
now i don't have a kebab shop i don't
know where that's come from obviously
that's based on racial stereotype
um
but when we bring it up to the referee
and we tell them about this obviously
he's an old he's an old white man
himself so then they've turned around
and said that's not racist
you know that's that's that's not racist
that's just he's just this is banter
that's why i feel like there's no change
because we need more black and ethnic
minority people in the fa in higher
positions so that we can
you know
little teach and and and allow thank you
a very
very concrete point thank you for that
tom
what about that
uh
well i've uh you know obviously
completely uh agree and sympathize with
with what men were saying i think that
there is a review of football that's
going on and about to be presented
but it's to do with governance
and governance is
the one end of of one of the problems in
football
but there is
a massive amount that needs to be
tackled through
kind of fan behavior connection with
fans
for the sustainability of this game it
needs to be addressed because people are
being excluded people don't feel safe
going into stand
people are getting uh
you know
abuse online there is
uh
there is an extraordinary amount to
tackle here through the lens of football
because football can be the great
unifier and is the great unifier for so
many people but it's got to be about
everyone and people have to respect that
liam just picking up this point about as
well who's in charge who's visibly in
authority you know one of the most uh
biggest or uh stories of the of this
issue in football
uh or questions has been
why didn't john barnes become a manager
he went to celtic and
he was uh you know he was a great star
but you know our top managers now
guardiola too cool
though our top full footballers are
people of color hardly any in general
management hardly any
uh in coaching um
would that make a difference if some of
those guys
got into those top positions yeah
definitely i think cena's believing i
think someone like myself you wouldn't
see someone like myself on tv talking
about men's football you know 15 20
years ago and the platform that i have
now so times are changing but at the
same time you know when we talk about
managers you know points has gone into
management you know chris huten has gone
into management but this there has to be
a problem somewhere because we're being
blocked somehow because there's enough
black people in the world there's enough
you know ethnic minorities asian people
and there's not really any asian
footballers that seem to get to you know
where they need to get to so something
isn't right because it's being blocked
from somewhere and i think a lot of it
is like subconscious and unbiased racism
that's deep rooted at the core that
people don't even realize it because you
know we're not even being given an
opportunity to get a job we're not
asking to be given the opportunity based
upon our skin color but give us the
opportunity to go for the job and that's
i think what we're seeing now and i
think people are now saying well there's
more people like you on tv you're just a
token gesture well no it's been like
this for hundreds of years well people
like me haven't been on tv so clearly
there was a problem we've got to call
the halt there because that's all we
have time for this evening
it just remained for me to say thank you
to our panelists here in the studio
leanne sanderson tom thirwal
dr martha newsom and azeem rafiq
of course it's you at home who are at
the center of this conversation and if
you'd like to be part of the program
next time get in touch email the great
debate at sky dot uk
and for now i want to thank everybody on
our viewers panel thank you for
very thoughtful contributions tonight on
a very difficult topic it's really great
and
for you at home keep talking and we'll
see you again same time next week for
the great debate
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
you